Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode contains violence against children that won't be suitable for all listeners. The small, rural property of Hinterkäifeck lay approximately 70km north of the German city of Munich. Set against Bavaria's flat, sweeping farmlands, meadows and pine forests, the acreage earned
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用或我们网站上本期节目的简介。今天的节目包含针对儿童的暴力内容，并非适合所有听众。位于德国慕尼黑市以北约70公里处，坐落着辛特凯费克这处偏僻的乡村房产。这片土地以巴伐利亚平坦开阔的农田、草地和松林为背景，其非官方名称
its unofficial name from a nearby hamlet called Käifeck, with Hinter being German for behind. Built in 1863, the single-story stone farmhouse was shaped like the Lederl. The living quarters occupied the longer portion of the building, while a barn, stables and engine room were at the other end. Outside, the large yard featured a well, crop fields, livestock pastures and a tool shed that also functioned as a laundry room and bakery. It was an isolated spot, the closest neighbour was half a kilometre away, and the nearest village was even further.
源自附近一个名为凯费克的小村庄，其中“欣特”在德语中是“后面”的意思。这栋建于1863年的单层石头农舍呈“L”形。起居室占据了建筑较长的部分，而谷仓、马厩和机房则位于另一端。在屋外，宽阔的院子里有一口水井、农田、牲畜牧场和一个兼作洗衣房和面包房的工具棚。这是一个偏僻的地方，最近的邻居在半公里外，最近的村庄则更远。
In 1922, Hinterkäifeck was owned and operated by three generations of the Gruber-Gabrielle family, fronted by 63-year-old Andreas Gruber and his 72-year-old wife Cecilia. Their 35-year-old daughter, Victoria Gabriel, also lived at the farmstead along with her two children, two-year-old Joseph and seven-year-old Cecilia, who was named after her grandmother, but went by the nickname Ceeley. Ceeley attended primary school in the nearby municipality of Weidhofen, with classes scheduled six days a week, including Saturdays. On Saturday, April 1, 1922, Ceeley was absent from school.
1922年，辛特凯费克由格鲁伯-加布里埃尔家族的三代人拥有和经营，由63岁的安德烈亚斯·格鲁伯和72岁的妻子塞西莉亚带头。他们35岁的女儿维多利亚·加布里埃尔也和她的两个孩子——两岁的约瑟夫和七岁的塞西莉亚一起住在农庄里。七岁的塞西莉亚是以她祖母的名字命名的，但大家都叫她小名西莉。西莉在附近魏多芬市镇的小学上学，每周上课六天，包括星期六。在1922年4月1日星期六这一天，西莉没有去上学。
It was not unusual, given she was prone to illness and was noticeably exhausted the day before. Her teacher led the class in the Lord's Prayer to help Ceeley recover before moving on with their studies. Later that afternoon, two coffee merchants delivering an order to Hinterkäifeck noticed all of the doors on the property were locked and nothing stirred within. They could hear a dog barking from inside the stables accompanied by the sounds of cattle. The merchants went up the road to a neighbouring property and informed the Schlittenbauer family
考虑到她容易生病且前一天明显筋疲力尽，这并不罕见。她的老师带领全班朗诵主祷文以帮助西莉恢复，然后才继续上课。那天下午晚些时候，两名给辛特凯费克送货的咖啡商人发现该房产的所有门都锁着，里面毫无动静。他们能听到马厩里面有狗叫声，伴随着牛叫声。商人们顺着路走到邻近的一处房产，并通知施利滕鲍尔家族
that Hinterkäifeck appeared deserted. Saturdays were typically busy for the Gruber-Gabrielle family, with members often sighted working around the farm. Yet, the pastures remained empty. The next morning, two friends of the household waited by the front gate to meet Victoria Gabriel on their weekly walk to Sunday Mass. She failed to appear, so the pair continued onwards without her. Other passes by were also beginning to notice the inactivity at Hinterkäifeck.
称辛特凯费克似乎荒废了。星期六对格鲁伯-加布里埃尔家族来说通常很忙碌，经常能看到成员在农场周围劳作。然而，牧场却空无一人。第二天早上，这户人家的两个朋友在前门等着，准备在他们每周去主日弥撒的路上偶遇维多利亚·加布里埃尔。她没有出现，于是两人没有等她就继续前行了。其他路人也开始注意到辛特凯费克异常安静。
When no one greeted the postman on Monday, he peered through the kitchen window expecting to see people bustling about, but the room was empty. At 9am on Tuesday, April 4, a mechanic arrived for a scheduled appointment to repair a diesel engine. He too heard the cattle mooing and dog barking from within the stables, but his knocks to the front door went unanswered, and there was no smoke coming from the chimney. Thinking the family must have stepped out, he went to inspect the engine room and noticed the lock was broken and easily removable.
周一没有人迎接邮递员时，他透过厨房的窗户往里看，本以为会看到人们忙碌的身影，但房间里空无一人。4月5日星期二上午9点，一名机械师按预约前来修理柴油发动机。他也听到马厩里传出牛的哞叫声和狗叫声，但他敲前门却无人应答，烟囱里也没有冒烟。他心想这家人一定出门了，于是去检查机房，发现锁已经坏了，而且很容易拆卸。
He carried the engine to the tool shed and spent the next 4 and a half hours fixing it. Afterwards, as he walked across the courtyard, he noticed the previously locked door to the barn was now wide open, and the family's pat, a German spitz watchdog, had been removed from the stables and was now tied up by the front door, snarling. The mechanic assumed someone had since returned home, but was confused as to why they hadn't approached him. He too visited the neighbouring Schlittenbauer residence to report on Hinterkäifeck's unusual stillness.
他把发动机搬到工具棚，花了一个半小时将其修好。之后，当他穿过庭院时，他发现先前锁着的谷仓门现在大敞着，而家族养的看门狗——一只德国斯佩茨犬——已经被从马厩里放出来，现在被拴在前门旁，正龇牙咧嘴。机械师以为有人已经回家了，但对他们为什么没有接近他感到困惑。他也走访了邻近的施利滕鲍尔住所，报告了辛特凯费克的不寻常寂静。
Concerned for the family, 48-year-old Lorenz Schlittenbauer sent his two young sons to check if anyone was home. They found the entire farmhouse locked with no lights on inside. All was silent, except for the cattle's loud, frantic-sounding mooing. Cecilia had inherited Hinterkäifeck at age 35, following the death of her first husband in 1885, with whom she had two children. The following year, she married the property's farmhand, 27-year-old Andreas Gruber. Generally viewed as helpful, Andreas was willing to lend a hand on his neighbour's farms,
出于对这户人家的担忧，48岁的洛伦茨·施利滕鲍尔派他的两个年幼的儿子去查看是否有人在家。他们发现整个农舍都锁着，里面没有开灯。四周一片寂静，除了牛只高亢而听起来很惊慌的哞叫声。塞西莉亚在1885年她的第一任丈夫去世后，以35岁的年纪继承了辛特凯费克，她与前夫育有两个孩子。第二年，她嫁给了该房产的农场雇工、27岁的安德烈亚斯·格鲁伯。安德烈亚斯通常被认为很乐于助人，愿意在邻居的农场上帮忙，
but was otherwise a socially withdrawn person. He and Cecilia had three daughters, yet only their first-born, Victoria, survived infancy. The Grubers were a private family who rarely interacted with others. Gossop had dictated Andreas beat his wife, and that his two deceased children had passed away from mistreatment and starvation. Unsavory rumours about Andreas' unsettling relationship with his daughter Victoria gained validity when, at age 16, she admitted to her neighbour that her father was forcing himself on her, and she could not bear the sight of him.
但在其他方面是一个社交孤立的人。他和塞西莉亚育有三个女儿，但只有他们的长女维多利亚度过了婴儿期。格鲁伯一家是个注重隐私的家庭，很少与他人交往。流言蜚语称安德烈亚斯殴打妻子，并且他死去的两个孩子是因为虐待和饥荒而夭折的。关于安德烈亚斯与女儿维多利亚令人不安的关系的不堪传闻，在维多利亚16岁时向邻居承认她的父亲强迫她，而她无法忍受看到父亲的面孔时，得到了证实。
Cecilia's two children from her previous marriage eventually moved out of Hinterkäifeck, leaving Victoria behind. Tall, slim and strong, Victoria did more than her fair share of labour on the farm. She had a serious disposition, but was the most social member of her family, performing as a leading member of the church choir and attending mass every Sunday. By the time she turned 27, Victoria was engaged to a man named Carl Gabriel, and the pair were married in April of 1914. Following their union, Victoria and Carl were granted the deed to Hinterkäifeck.
塞西莉亚与前夫所生的两个孩子最终搬出了辛特凯费克，只留下维多利亚。维多利亚身材高挑、苗条而强壮，她在农场里承担了远超应分之劳的农活。她性格严肃，但却是家中社交最多的人，作为教堂唱诗班的主唱并每个星期天都去参加弥撒。到她27岁时，维多利亚与一个名叫卡尔·加布里埃尔的男子订婚，两人于1914年4月结婚。结婚后，维多利亚和卡尔获得了辛特凯费克的地契。
Andreas and Cecilia remained living at the property and working on the land. Married life was fraught for the newlyweds, primarily due to Andreas' dislike of his son-in-law. Carl complained to friends that Andreas bullied and tormented him, sometimes by depriving him of meals. He returned to his parents' home a few weeks after the wedding, but they insisted he made the relationship work. As Victoria was the gruber's only child, ownership of Hinterkäifeck would eventually
安德烈亚斯和塞西莉亚继续住在该房产并在这片土地上劳作。新婚生活对这对新婚夫妇来说充满摩擦，主要是因为安德烈亚斯不喜欢他的女婿。卡尔向朋友抱怨安德烈亚斯欺负和折磨他，有时甚至剥夺他的饭食。婚礼几周后他回到了父母家，但父母坚持让他维系这段婚姻。由于维多利亚是格鲁伯唯一的孩子，如果这对夫妇有孩子，辛特凯费克的所有权最终将
pass to the Gabriel family, should the couple have children. Less than four months into their marriage, Carl enlisted to fight in World War I. When he left for the front lines in France, Victoria was pregnant with their first child. Carl was killed in action before the year's end, and his daughter, Cecilia, was born one month later. Three-quarters of Carl's land title passed to his newborn, and the remainder went to his widow, making Victoria the sole adult owner of Hinterkäifeck. Six months after Carl's death, Victoria and her father Andreas were convicted of having
转给加布里埃尔家族。结婚不到四个月，卡尔就应征入伍参加第一次世界大战。当他动身前往法国前线时，维多利亚正怀着他们的第一个孩子。卡尔在年底前阵亡，一个月后他们的女儿塞西莉亚出生了。卡尔四分之三的土地产权归了他的新生女儿，其余部分归了他的遗孀，这使得维多利亚成为辛特凯费克唯一的成年所有者。卡尔死后六个月，维多利亚和她的父亲安德烈亚斯被判犯有
an incestuous relationship. The charges related to crimes occurring between 1907 and 1910, when Andreas was aged in his early 50s and Victoria in her early 20s. Victoria received a one-month prison sentence and Andreas one year. Both returned to Hinterkäifeck upon their release, and the family resumed their reclusive existence. In September 1919, Victoria gave birth to her second child, Joseph. Their birth certificate listed the initials LS as Joseph's father, which correlated with
乱伦关系罪。这些指控涉及1907年至1910年间发生的罪行，当时安德烈亚斯年仅50岁出头，维多利亚20岁出头。维多利亚被判处一个月的监禁，安德烈亚斯被判处一年。两人刑满释放后都回到了辛特凯费克，这个家庭恢复了他们隐世的生活。1919年9月，维多利亚生下了她的第二个孩子约瑟夫。他们的出生证明上将缩写LS列为约瑟夫的父亲，这与
a brief relationship Victoria had a year prior with her widowed neighbour, Lorenz Schlittenbauer. Regardless, Townsfolk suspected the child was a product of Victoria's incestuous relationship with her father. The 1920s were a time of political and social upheaval for Bavarians impacted by World War I, but the residents of Hinterkäifeck found themselves in a stable financial position. The family of five were well off tending crops and raising cows, oxen, piglets and chickens, although they had a reputation for being stingy with money. In November 1920, the family hired 23-year-old Kreschens Riga as their living maid.
维多利亚一年前与她的丧偶邻居洛伦茨·施利滕鲍尔有过的一段短暂恋情相吻合。无论如何，镇民们怀疑这个孩子是维多利亚与她父亲乱伦关系的产物。20世纪20年代对受到第一次世界大战影响的巴伐利亚人来说是一个政治和社会动荡的时期，但辛特凯费克的居民发现自己处于稳定的财务状况中。这五口之家靠着耕种农作物以及饲养奶牛、公牛、小猪和鸡过着优渥的生活，尽管他们以对金钱吝啬而闻名。1920年11月，这家人雇用了23岁的克雷申斯·里加作为他们的住家女佣。
While at the farm, Kreschens overheard Andreas order his daughter not to remarry, as he would be hers as long as he lived. Andreas once kept Victoria locked in a closet when a suitor arrived to ask for her hand in marriage. Then in late 1921, Kreschens entered the barn and witnessed Andreas and Victoria engaged in sexual activity. Victoria later explained that if she had known Kreschens was about to enter, she, quote, would not have surrendered to her father.
在农场期间，克雷申斯无意中听到安德烈亚斯命令他的女儿不得再婚，因为只要他活着，她就永远属于他。当有追求者来向维多利亚求婚时，安德烈亚斯曾把维多利亚锁在储藏室里。然后在1921年底，克雷申斯进入谷仓，目睹了安德烈亚斯和维多利亚正在进行性行为。维多利亚后来解释说，如果她知道克雷申斯要进来，她，引述原话，是不会向父亲妥协的。
Kreschens resigned 10 months into her employment, and the family began searching for a replacement. The following year, in March of 1922, Hinterkäifeck was disturbed by a series of strange events. First, a set of house keys went missing. Then, a Munich-based newspaper was found on the property. No one in the area subscribed to the publication, or had recently travelled that far. Andreas queried the postman, but he had no idea how it got there. On the morning of Thursday, March 30, Andreas noticed the padlock on the engine room door was broken.
克雷申斯工作10个月后辞职，这家人开始寻找替代者。第二年，即1922年3月，辛特凯费克发生了一系列奇怪的事件，打破了平静。首先是一串房屋钥匙不翼而飞。接着，在房产里发现了一份慕尼黑当地的报纸。该地区没有人订购这份出版物，也没有人最近去过那么远的地方。安德烈亚斯向邮递员询问，但他也不知道报纸是怎么到那里的。3月30日星期四早上，安德烈亚斯发现机房门上的挂锁坏了。
Nothing appeared to be missing, but snow had been tracked inside, indicating someone had entered. He noticed two sets of footprints in the snow heading from the rear fields to his farmstead. But there were no tracks leading away. Andreas encountered his neighbour, Lorenz Schlittenbauer, out in the fields, and mentioned the break-in, footprints and missing keys. Lorenz hadn't noticed anything suspicious, but offered to contact police and lend Andreas his revolver for protection.
似乎没有什么东西丢失，但里面有踩过雪的痕迹，表明有人进去过。他注意到雪地里有两组脚印从后面的田野通向他的农庄。但没有通往外面的脚印。安德烈亚斯在田野里遇到了邻居洛伦茨·施利滕鲍尔，并提到了入室盗窃、脚印和丢失的钥匙。洛伦茨没有注意到任何可疑之处，但主动提出联系警方并把自己的左轮手枪借给安德烈亚斯以作防身之用。
Andreas refused. He didn't want police in his home, and felt capable of defending himself. Later, Andreas ran into a different neighbour, expressing his belief that rogues were inside his house. Andreas rejected his neighbour's invitation to search the property, claiming he was not afraid. When he returned home later, he noticed the cow was loose from the stables and running around in the yard.
安德烈亚斯拒绝了。他不想让警察进他的家里，并觉得自己有能力保护自己。后来，安德烈亚斯遇到了另一个邻居，向他表达了自己认为有流氓潜入家中的看法。安德烈亚斯拒绝了邻居搜查房产的邀请，声称自己并不害怕。当他随后回家时，他发现奶牛从马厩里挣脱出来，在院子里到处乱跑。
That same day, Victoria Gabriel was out looking for a new maid. She visited a woman named Francesca to inquire whether her sister, 45-year-old Maria Baumgartner, would be interested in the role. Maria was a deeply religious and introverted woman who had worked as a maid since her mother's death in 1904. She often encountered discrimination due to her slight intellectual disability and a birth defect that left one leg significantly shorter than the other. As such, Francesca graciously accepted the hentakifec job on behalf of her older sister,
同一天，维多利亚·加布里埃尔外出寻找新女佣。她拜访了一位名叫弗兰切斯卡的妇人，询问她的妹妹、45岁的玛丽亚·鲍姆加特纳是否有兴趣担任这个角色。玛丽亚是一个极其虔诚且内向的女人，自从1904年母亲去世以来一直担任女佣。由于轻度智力残疾以及导致一条腿明显比另一条腿短的先天缺陷，她经常遭遇歧视。因此，弗兰切斯卡欣然代表她的姐姐接受了辛特凯费克的工作，
with Maria scheduled to arrive to the farm the following day. That evening, as members of the Gruber Gabriel family lay in their respective beds, they heard muffled footsteps pacing the attic above. Armed with a torch, Andreas made his way upstairs to investigate, but only found large amounts of straw scattered across the floor. At school the following morning of Friday, March 31, seven-year-old Sealy Gabriel was noticeably exhausted and fell asleep in class. The teacher woke her and asked if something was wrong.
并安排玛丽亚于第二天抵达农场。那天晚上，当格鲁伯·加布里埃尔一家的成员分别躺在各自的床铺上时，他们听到沉闷的脚步声在头顶的阁楼上踱步。安德烈亚斯手持手电筒上楼查看，却只发现地板上散落着大量的稻草。第二天早上，即3月31日星期五，在学校里，七岁的西莉·加布里埃尔明显筋疲力尽并在课堂上睡着了。老师叫醒她并问她是否有什么不对劲。
Sealy made no mention of the attic noises the night prior. Instead, she said her family had spent the night searching for her mother, who had run into the woods after a violent altercation with Andreas. Fears that Victoria had drowned in a nearby river subsided at daybreak when she was discovered sitting on a tree stump. Meanwhile, at hentakifec, Andreas conducted another thorough search of the farmhouse, but was unable to determine the source of the noises the night before. He and Victoria left the farm in the afternoon to complete several errands in the nearby
西莉没有提及前一晚阁楼上的声音。相反，她说她的家人花了一夜时间寻找她的母亲，因为母亲在与安德烈亚斯发生暴力争吵后跑进了树林里。黎明时分，当人们发现维多利亚正坐在一截树桩上时，担心她淹死在附近河流中的恐惧随之消散。与此同时，在辛特凯费克，安德烈亚斯对农舍进行了另一次彻底的搜查，但无法确定前一晚声音的来源。他和维多利亚于下午离开农场，去附近的
town of Schrobenhausen. While there, Andreas told a hardware store clerk about the troubles on his farm, adding, I am not afraid, I have already prepared my rifle. Victoria mentioned the unsettling events to another shopkeeper, expressing fear that somebody was determined to break into their property. At five o'clock that afternoon, Maria Baumgartner arrived to Hentakifec, escorted by her sister Franziska. Cecilia and young Joseph were the only family members home at the time.
施罗本豪森镇办理几件跑腿的事。在那里，安德烈亚斯向五金店店员讲述了他在农场遇到的麻烦，并补充道：“我不害怕，我已经准备好我的步枪了。”维多利亚向另一位店员提及了这些令人不安的事件，表达了对有人决心闯入他们房产的恐惧。当天下午五点，玛丽亚·鲍姆加特纳在她的姐姐弗兰西斯卡的护送下抵达了辛特凯费克。当时家里只有塞西莉亚和年幼的约瑟夫。
Maria was led to the maids' quarters tucked away off the kitchen, where she'd reside throughout her employment. Franziska stayed to help Maria get settled, but was eager to return home before dark. Though it was spring, the snowy weather had been remarkably cold, and storms were anticipated for later that night. Franziska farewelled her sister and exited the house. Franziska sensed Hentakifec was a nearly lonely place. As she approached the dirt road, she turned to see Maria running towards her.
玛丽亚被领到位于厨房一角隐蔽的女佣住处，她将在那里度过整个受雇期间。弗兰西斯卡留下来帮玛丽亚安顿，但急于在天黑前赶回家。尽管正值春天，但降雪天气异常寒冷，预计当天晚些时候会有风暴。弗兰西斯卡向妹妹道别并离开了房子。弗兰西斯卡感觉到辛特凯费克是一个非常孤独的地方。当她走近泥土路时，她转身看到玛丽亚正朝她跑来。
Maria hugged her sister firmly, wanting to say goodbye again. Franziska wasn't particularly close to her siblings, but she returned to the odd embrace and promised to visit again soon. It was over the weekend that Hentakifec fell unusually quiet. Ceile failed to show up for her Saturday school class, and the remainder of the family were absent from the fields. The house was locked up and lifeless, with the only sounds coming from the animals secured inside the stable.
玛丽亚紧紧地拥抱了她的姐姐，想要再次道别。弗兰西斯卡与她的兄弟姐妹并不是特别亲近，但她回应了这个奇怪的拥抱，并承诺很快会再来探望。正是在这个周末，辛特凯费克陷入了不同寻常的寂静。塞莉没有去上周六的学校课，其余的家人也没有出现在田野里。房子锁着且毫无生气，唯一的声响来自被关在马厩里的动物。
On Tuesday, April 4, Lorenz Schlittenbauer and his two young sons collected two other neighbors, Jacob Siegel and Michael Pell, and headed to Hentakifec, concerned that Andreas Gruber may have taken his own life. They arrived at around 5pm to discover all the animals were secured away, and the doors to the building were all locked, except for the one to the engine room. Inside, the group attempted to open a second interior door that led into the barn, but a wooden beam had been propped up on the other side, preventing entry. After some heavy pushing, the beam gave way, and the men entered the dim barn with flashlights
4月5日星期二，洛伦茨·施利滕鲍尔和他的两个年幼儿子叫上了另外两个邻居雅各布·西格尔和迈克尔·佩尔，一行人前往辛特凯费克，担心安德烈亚斯·格鲁伯可能已经自杀。他们在下午5点左右到达，发现所有的动物都被关好了，房子的门也都锁着，只有机房的门除外。在里面，几个人试图打开通往谷仓的第二道内门，但另一侧被一根木梁顶住，无法进入。在几经用力推搡后，木梁松脱了，男人们手持手电筒进入了昏暗的谷仓，
in hand. One of the stables was open, and a cow had broken loose from its pen. Lorenz climbed over a board, slipping on some hay as he went. Behind him, Michael shuffled his way through the dark. Suddenly, he yelled out, there's a foot. Lorenz looked down and saw a foot sticking out from a bale of hay. He pulled it towards him, uncovering the body of Andreas Gruber, dressed in trousers and an undershirt.
手里拿着手电筒。其中一个马厩是开着的，一头牛从栏杆里挣脱了出来。洛伦茨爬过一块木板，走的时候在一些干草上滑了一下。在他身后，迈克尔在黑暗中摸索着前进。突然，他大喊道：“有一只脚。”洛伦茨低头看去，看到一只脚从一堆干草中伸出来。他把它向自己这边拉，露出了穿着裤子和内衣的安德烈亚斯·格鲁伯的尸体。
His face was covered in blood, and he had suffered significant head injuries. Lorenz could see three more bodies partially concealed under the straw. Jacob and Michael staggered out of the barn in shock, but Lorenz remained behind and inspected the three other corpses, finding Cecilia, Victoria and Ceeley with severe head wounds. Both Cecilia and Victoria were fully dressed, and Ceeley wore her nightgown. Lorenz dragged the seven-year-old towards a wall where the lighting was better. Jacob returned and asked him to stop and wait for the police. But Lorenz replied, I'm looking for my son.
他的脸布满鲜血，头部受了重伤。洛伦茨可以看到稻草下还部分藏着另外三具尸体。雅各布和迈克尔震惊地踉跄着逃出谷仓，但洛伦茨留下来检查了其他三具尸体，发现塞西莉亚、维多利亚和西莉头部都有严重伤口。塞西莉亚和维多利亚都穿着整齐，西莉则穿着睡衣。洛伦茨把这个七岁的小女孩拖到光线较好的墙边。雅各布回来叫他停下并等待警察。但洛伦茨回答说：“我在找我的儿子。”
Two-year-old Joseph was nowhere to be seen. Lorenz proceeded towards the adjoining stables, noticing a pickaxe leaning against the wall. The family dog was tied up inside, despite the mechanic having seen it restrained by the front door only hours earlier. The dog had a wound above its right eye and recoiled and shook when the men approached. The cattle were making a lot of noise, prompting Lorenz to order Jacob to throw them some hay. Lorenz continued to the door which connected the stables to the living quarters, finding it unlocked.
两岁的约瑟夫不见踪影。洛伦茨朝相邻的马厩走去，注意到一把镐头靠在墙上。家里的狗被拴在里面，尽管机械师几个小时前才刚看到它被拴在前门。这根狗的右眼上方有伤口，当男人们靠近时，它畏缩并颤抖着。牛群发出很大的噪音，促使洛伦茨命令雅各布给它们扔些干草。洛伦茨继续走向连接马厩和起居室的门，发现它没有锁。
He entered the kitchen and searched the house, finding Joseph Stryler in a bedroom with a woman's skirt draped over the top. Lorenz pulled the skirt aside and saw the toddler, quote, with his head shattered. He then unlocked the rear door to let Jacob and Michael in. Jacob questioned where he had gotten the key from, to which Lorenz responded it had been in the lock. In the maid's quarters, a mattress had been pulled from the bed frame onto the floor. Two feet poked out from under a check to duvet on top, one wearing a shoe and the other bare.
他进入厨房并搜查了房子，在卧室里找到了约瑟夫·施特里勒，上面盖着一条女人的裙子。洛伦茨掀开裙子，看到那个幼儿，“引述原话，脑袋都被砸碎了。”然后他打开后门让雅各布和迈克尔进来。雅各布质问他从哪里弄来的钥匙，洛伦茨回答说钥匙一直插在锁上。在女佣的住处，一张床垫从床架上被扯到了地板上。上面盖着一个格子羽绒被，两只脚从下面露出来，一只穿着鞋，另一只赤脚。
Lorenz removed the blanket and revealed the body of Hintakifex recently hired maid, Maria Baumgartner, who had also endured a horrific attack. Jacob and Michael rushed to the nearby village of Groban to raise the alarm. Lorenz asked one of his sons to inform the local mayor while he stayed behind to look after the livestock. The mayor notified nearby authorities and placed a call to the police chief in Munich. News of the gruesome massacre spread quickly and by 6pm a crowd had gathered at Hintakifex. As authorities had yet to arrive, a notably calm Lorenz took it upon himself to escort
洛伦茨掀开毯子，露出了辛特凯费克新雇的女佣玛丽亚·鲍姆加特纳的尸体，她也遭受了可怕的袭击。雅各布和迈克尔冲向附近的格罗班村拉响警报。洛伦茨让他的一个儿子去通知当地的镇长，而自己则留下来照看牲畜。镇长通知了附近的当局，并给慕尼黑的警察局长打了电话。这起骇人听闻的大屠杀的消息迅速传开，到下午6点，人群已经在辛特凯费克聚集。由于当局尚未赶到，一个表现得异常冷静的洛伦茨自告奋勇地护送
visitors through the property, pointing out the bodies as they went. One neighbor cautioned him against allowing anyone else in in case they disturbed the crime scene, but Lorenz replied that they were already there and there was nothing he could do about it. More people traipsed through the building, with one guest reportedly pausing in the kitchen to fix themselves a snack. Five investigators were dispatched from Munich along with two tracker dogs, but a slow journey meant they didn't arrive until 1.30am.
访客穿过房产，一路上指出尸体所在的位置。一位邻居警告他不要让其他人进来，以免破坏犯罪现场，但洛伦茨回答说他们已经进来了，他也无可奈何。更多的人在建筑物里穿行，据报道其中一位客人还在厨房停下来给自己弄点零食。慕尼黑派出了五名调查人员以及两只追踪犬，但由于行程缓慢，他们直到凌晨1点30天才抵达。
As it was too dark for them to inspect the crime scene, they rested at the mayor's home until first light. They arrived to Hintakifex at 5.30am the following morning, where they found Lorenz Schlittenbauer still watching over the farm. Lead investigator Detective George Reingruber entered the barn. The bodies of Cecilia and Victoria were beyond the threshold. Andreas and Cili were still positioned by the wall where Lorenz had left them. All four had sustained fatal blows to the skull, but there was no blood spatter anywhere,
由于天太黑无法检查犯罪现场，他们在镇长家里休息到天亮。第二天早上5点30分，他们抵达辛特凯费克，发现洛伦茨·施利滕鲍尔仍在看守农场。首席调查员乔治·赖因格鲁伯侦探进入了谷仓。塞西莉亚和维多利亚的尸体就在门槛外。安德烈亚斯和西莉仍然靠在洛伦茨离开时他们所在的墙边。这四人的头骨都受到了致命的打击，但没有任何地方有血迹喷溅，
except on the door that led to the stables. Upon inspecting the pickaxe propped against the wall, Detective Reingruber noted it was clean, but took red-brown spots on the handle for blood stains. Lorenz informed the detective he believed this was the murder weapon, and the cattle must have licked it clean. Investigators made their way into the kitchen, where they noticed a few blood spots on the threshold leading to the maids room. Inside, Mireia was fully dressed and lying in the fetal position on the floor, appearing
除了通往马厩的门上。在检查靠在墙上的镐头时，赖因格鲁伯侦探注意到它是干净的，但把手上的红褐色斑点当作血迹。洛伦茨告诉侦探，他相信这就是凶器，牛一定把上面的血迹舔干净了。调查人员走进厨房，注意到通往女佣房间的门槛上有几个血迹。在里面，玛丽亚穿着整齐，以胎儿的姿势躺在地板上，看起来
as though she had been attacked before she prepared for bed. There were also some small blood stains in the hallway leading to the family's bedrooms, but there were no bloody footprints. The room Victoria shared with her two children had been ransacked, with cupboard doors flung open and an empty purse, papers, a notebook, and a watch strewn across her bed. But no other areas in the house showed any signs of burglary. The roof of Joseph Stroller had been torn apart by a forceful blow, and the killer had used one of Victoria's skirts to conceal the boy's body.
就像她在准备睡觉前遭到袭击一样。通往家庭卧室的走廊里也有一些小的血迹，但没有带血的脚印。维多利亚和她的两个孩子共用的房间被洗劫一空，橱柜门大敞着，一个空钱包、文件、笔记本和一块手表散落在她的床上。但屋内的其他区域没有显示出任何入室盗窃的迹象。约瑟夫·施特里勒的头顶被猛烈的一击撕裂，凶手用维多利亚的一条裙子盖住了男孩的尸体。
In the attic above the barn, investigators noticed hay had been spread across the floor and featured several impressions, as though one or more people had lain there. Bacon rinds as well as human excrement were found in the corner. There were also some loose tiles on the roof that could be raised slightly to view the living quarters and yard outside. As all external doors to the property had been locked from the inside, investigators wondered how the perpetrator exited the building following the murders. Two police dogs were sent out into the woods to track down evidence, but nothing was found.
在谷仓上方的阁楼里，调查人员注意到干草铺满了地板，并有几个压痕，就像一个人或多个人曾躺在那里一样。角落里发现了熏肉皮以及人类粪便。屋顶上还有一些松动的瓦片，可以稍微抬起以观察起居室和外面的院子。由于该房产的所有外部门都是从里面反锁的，调查人员想知道凶手在谋杀后是如何离开建筑物的。两支警犬被派往树林中追踪证据，但什么也没找到。
It had rained in recent days, and much of the snow that had previously covered the ground had since melted away. Detective Ron Gruber noted in his report, There are no tangible clues about the persons or offenders. Statements were taken from local residents, including the three men who discovered the crime scene, Lorenz Schlittenbauer, Jacob Siegel and Michael Pell. Lorenz insisted he hadn't let anyone else enter the property after finding the bodies, despite several statements to the contrary.
最近几天一直在下雨，先前覆盖地面的大部分雪此后已经融化。罗恩·格鲁伯侦探在报告中指出：“关于个人或罪犯，没有切实线索。”当地居民接受了讯问，包括发现犯罪现场的三名男子：洛伦茨·施利滕鲍尔、雅各布·西格尔和迈克尔·佩尔。洛伦茨坚称他在发现尸体后没有让任何人进入该房产，尽管有多份声明与此相反。
He claimed the family had 100,000 marks in cash stashed on the premises, yet investigators only found a five-mark bill tucked away in a prayer book. As such, robbery was the suspected motive for the massacre. However, the perpetrator ignored many valuables in the home, including jewellery, watches, and more than 2,200 marks worth of gold and silver coins. Witness statements were used to piece together a probable timeline of events. Given Sealy's absence from school on Saturday, April 1, the murders were estimated to have occurred between 8pm and 11pm on Friday, March 31.
他声称这家人在住所里藏有10万马克现金，然而调查人员只在祈祷书里夹着一张5马克的纸币。因此，抢劫被怀疑是大屠杀的动机。然而，凶手忽视了家里的许多贵重物品，包括珠宝、手表以及价值超过2200马克的金银币。证人证言被用来拼凑事件可能的发生时间线。鉴于西莉在4月1日星期六缺课，谋杀估计发生在3月31日星期五晚上8点到11点之间。
Experiments concluded that screaming inside the barn could not be heard in the house. Furthermore, the internal door leading from the house into the barn was narrow, enabling only one individual to enter at a time. Thus, it seemed unlikely the entire family were killed at once inside the barn, as some would have had the opportunity to flee. It appeared as though they were lured in one at a time. Andreas Gruber's previous remarks to neighbours that a cow had inexplicably escaped into the yard led investigators to presume this was the technique used to draw the family out of the house.
实验得出结论，谷仓内的尖叫声在屋里是听不见的。此外，从屋里通往谷仓的内门很窄，一次只能容纳一个人进入。因此，全家人似乎不太可能同时在谷仓内被杀，因为有些人会有逃跑的机会。他们看起来像是被一个接一个地诱骗进去的。安德烈亚斯·格鲁伯先前对邻居说的一头牛莫名其妙地逃到院子里的话，让调查人员推测这是将这家人引出屋子的手段。
Given that Lorenz Schlittenbauer moved two of the bodies, the order of the killings couldn't be confirmed. Police suspected Victoria and Sealy were the first victims, as they were both fully dressed. Next was Andreas, who was in the process of changing into his nightclothes, followed by Sealy, who was ready for bed. After that, the killer entered the living quarters and struck Maria from behind, before murdering Joseph. The family's entire bread supply and several pieces of smoked meat were missing. This, coupled with witness reports that the Hinterkäifeck livestock were quiet
鉴于洛伦茨·施利滕鲍尔移动了两具尸体，行凶的顺序无法确认。警方怀疑维多利亚和西莉是第一批受害者，因为她们都穿着整齐。接下来是正在换夜衣的安德烈亚斯，然后是准备睡觉的西莉。之后，凶手进入起居室，从背后袭击了玛丽亚，然后谋杀了约瑟夫。这家人所有的面包供应和几块熏肉都不见了。这与目击者称辛特凯费克的牲畜在屠杀后立即保持安静的报告相结合，
immediately following the massacre, led to the belief that the killer remained at the property after the slaughter, possibly for several days, feeding themselves and the animals. The delay in discovering the bodies and disruptions to the crime scene hampered forensic evidence, but the investigation was minimal regardless. No fingerprints were collected, even though this method had been established more than a decade earlier, and only five photographs were taken of the crime scene. Autopsies were conducted on the grounds of Hinterkäifeck, overseen by a crowd of onlookers. A door was placed across two wooden trestles to function as a makeshift table.
让人相信凶手在屠杀后仍然留在房产里，可能呆了好几天，自己进食并喂养动物。发现尸体的延迟以及对犯罪现场的破坏阻碍了法医证据的收集，但无论如何，调查都微乎其微。没有采集到指纹，尽管这种方法在一十多年前就已经建立，而且犯罪现场只拍了五张照片。尸检在辛特凯费克的土地上进行，由一群旁观者监督。一块门被放在两个木制支架上，作为简易桌子。
The district court doctor confirmed all six victims had died from head injuries by the blunt edge of a farmyard tool, such as a pickaxe. The perpetrator appeared left-handed, as the majority of the wounds were inflicted on the right side of the victim's heads. Victoria had sustained the most injuries, including markings consistent with strangulation, and nine star-shaped wounds to her skull. Seven-year-old Sealy was the only victim who did not die instantly, enduring two to three hours of agony before finally succumbing to her injuries. It was believed had she received immediate medical attention, she would have survived.
地区法院医生确认所有六名受害者都是死于农场工具（如镐头）钝刃造成的头部损伤。凶手似乎是左撇子，因为大部分伤口都集中在受害者头部的右侧。维多利亚受到的伤害最多，包括与勒颈一致的痕迹以及头骨上的九处星形伤口。七岁的西莉是唯一没有立即死亡的受害者，在最终因伤身亡前经历了两个到三个小时的痛苦。人们认为如果她得到了及时的医疗救助，她本可以幸存下来。
The heads of all six victims were sent to the Pathology Institute at the University of Munich for further examination, and their bodies remained at Hinterkäifeck to await burial. As two officers carried Sealy's body inside the barn, they noticed a rope hanging down from the loft above, which had not been there moments earlier. They climbed up and sighted handprints on the dusty beam the rope was tied to. Police dogs were dispatched in an attempt to capture whoever had been hiding above, but no trace of the individual was found. The funerals for the Hinterkäifeck household were scheduled for Saturday, April 8.
所有六名受害者的头部都被送到慕尼黑大学病理学研究所进行进一步检查，他们的尸体留在辛特凯费克等待安葬。当两名警官把西莉的尸体抬进谷仓时，他们注意到一根绳子从上面的阁楼垂下来，而这根绳子几分钟前还不在那里。他们爬上去，在系着绳子的满是灰尘的横梁上看到了手印。警方派出了警犬试图抓获一直藏在上面的人，但没有发现任何痕迹。辛特凯费克一家的葬礼定于4月8日星期六举行。
Word incorrectly spread that the service was taking place on April 7, resulting in an influx of visitors to the area a day early. They planned to use the extra time to examine the site of the murders, only to find that police had cordoned off the crime scene. The following morning, Weidhofen's Catholic Church struggled to accommodate the approximately 3,000 mourners who had gathered. The six matching coffins were carried to the church on a wagon. Father Michael Haas told the congregation that God viewed murder as a terrible abomination,
有传言错误地称葬礼在4月7日举行，导致大量访客提前一天涌入该地区。他们计划利用额外的时间检查谋杀现场，却发现警察已经拉起了警戒线。第二天早上，魏多芬的天主教教堂几乎容纳不下聚集的约3000名哀悼者。六口一样的棺材被放在一辆马车上运到教堂。迈克尔·哈斯神父对会众说，上帝将谋杀视为一种可怕的憎恶，
and only a man with no spark of faith in his heart could commit such a horrific act. The five members of the Gruber Gabriel family and Maria Baumgartner were buried together in a mass grave, with the adults' coffins flanking the children's tiny caskets. Police announced a reward of 100,000 marks for information about the killer's identity. The amount was soon increased to 500,000 marks, and posters were distributed throughout the region to publicize the investigation. The murders had shocked and terrified the local community, and made newspaper headlines across the country.
只有心中没有一丝信仰的人才能犯下如此恐怖的罪行。格鲁伯·加布里埃尔一家的五名成员和玛丽亚·鲍姆加特纳被合葬在一个万人坑里，成年人的棺材夹在孩子们的小棺材两侧。警方悬赏10万马克征集有关凶手身份的信息。这笔金额很快增加到50万马克，海报在整个地区分发以宣传这项调查。谋杀案震惊并吓坏了当地社区，并登上了全国各地的报纸头条。
Fearful citizens began reporting their friends, neighbors and other individuals who they deemed suspicious. Rural residents were advised to be vigilant, especially at night, and to thoroughly search their properties each evening. They were also encouraged to keep large guard dogs for protection, look out for their neighbors, and avoid storing valuables or large sums of money in their homes. Tales of the strange events at Hinterkäifeck preceding the massacre spread, and several more bizarre incidents were reported.
恐惧的市民开始举报他们的朋友、邻居以及他们认为可疑的其他个人。乡村居民被建议保持警惕，特别是在夜间，并在每天晚上彻底搜查他们的房产。他们还被鼓励饲养大型看门狗以进行保护，关照邻居，并避免在家里存放贵重物品或大笔现金。辛特凯费克在屠杀前发生怪事的传说传开后，又有几起离奇事件被报道。
Two weeks before the murders, Father Haass supposedly found an anonymous donation of 700 gold marks in his church, which he suspected had been left by Victoria Gabriel. When he queried her about it, she reluctantly admitted to making the sizeable donation. A local carpenter reported that on Saturday, April 1, he walked past Hinterkäifeck at around 11.30pm. More than 24 hours after the murders were believed to have taken place. He saw a light shining from the oven inside the farmstead,
谋杀案发生前两周，哈斯神父据称在他的教堂里发现了一笔700金马克的匿名捐款，他怀疑这是维多利亚·加布里埃尔留下的。当他向她询问此事时，她不情愿地承认了这笔巨额捐款。一位当地木匠报告说，在4月1日星期六晚上11点30分左右，他走过辛特凯费克。在人们认为谋杀案发生24小时多之后。他看到农舍内的烤箱亮着灯，
and a curl of smoke coming from the chimney. He then noticed a figure holding a flashlight moving about in the yard. The figure began to approach, shining the light in his eyes. Somewhat spooked, the carpenter hurried home without stopping. In addition to robbery, other motives were also considered. The strangulation marks on Victoria hinted at it being a personal attack, and some speculated the murderer could be a scorned lover. Others believed the killings were a form of retribution for Andreas
烟囱里冒出一缕青烟。然后他注意到一个拿着手电筒的人影在院子里走动。这个人开始走近，把光照在他的眼睛上。木匠有些被吓到了，没有停下就匆忙赶回家中。除了抢劫之外，还考虑了其他动机。维多利亚身上的勒痕暗示这是一次针对个人的袭击，一些人猜测凶手可能是一个被抛弃的情人。另一些人则认为杀戮是对安德烈亚斯
and Victoria's incestuous relationship. Following the murders, victims' relatives embarked on a legal battle over ownership of Hinterkäifeck. As Sealy was the last to die, she had been the farm's sole owner for a brief period. Therefore, the Gabriel side of the family believed possession of the property should pass to her paternal grandparents. The matter was resolved out of court, with the Gabriels purchasing Hinterkäifeck from the Grubers for 3 million marks.
和维多利亚乱伦关系的报复。谋杀案发生后，受害者的亲属为辛特凯费克的所有权展开了一场法律战。由于西莉是最后一个死去的，她在短时间内曾是农场唯一的拥有者。因此，加布里埃尔家族认为该房产的所有权应该转给她的祖父母。庭外和解了这一问题，加布里埃尔家族以300万马克从格鲁伯家族手中买下了辛特凯费克。
In late February 1923, they decided to demolish the entire property. They commissioned an artist to paint a watercolour picture of the property beforehand, capturing the white farmhouse in a field of green, framed by budding trees. The next day, carpenters dismantling the roof trusses noticed several loose floorboards in the attic next to the staircase. They pried them up, revealing a small nest of hay underneath, along with a blood-stained mattock, a hand tool commonly used for clearing small trees and shrubs. It had a blunt horizontal axe head and a long wooden handle.
1923年2月下旬，他们决定拆除整个房产。他们事先委托了一位艺术家画了一幅房产的水彩画，捕捉了绿草地上白色的农舍，周围点缀着萌芽的树木。第二天，拆除屋顶桁架的木匠注意到楼梯旁阁楼上有几块松动的地板。他们撬开地板，发现下面有一个小干草窝，还有一个沾满血迹的锄头，这是一种常用于清理小树和灌木的手工工具。它有一个钝的水平斧头和一个长木柄。
Alongside it was a small metal hoop coated in dried blood. The tool had previously belonged to Andreas Gruber, as neighbours recognised the distinctive screw protruding from the handle that he had fitted during repairs. The screw perfectly matched the star-shaped injuries to Victoria's skull, and police declared the mattock as the murder weapon. Several days later, while clearing out the barn, excavators found a bloody penknife close to where the bodies had been found. Maintaining they had conducted a thorough search of the crime scene, investigators believed the killer returned to the farm to hide the mattock
旁边是一个沾满干血的小金属圈。这个工具以前属于安德烈亚斯·格鲁伯，因为邻居们认出了他在修理时装上去的从手柄上突出的独特螺丝。这颗螺丝与维多利亚头骨上的星形伤口完全吻合，警方宣布该锄头就是凶器。几天后，在清理谷仓时，挖掘人员在发现尸体的地方附近找到了一把带血的袖珍小刀。调查人员坚称他们对犯罪现场进行了彻底搜查，他们认为凶手在调查的风头过去后返回农场藏匿了锄头
and penknife once the heat of the investigation had died down. No fingerprints were recovered from either item. Given the social and cultural climate of Bavaria at the time, political motivations for the murders were also considered. The region was a hotbed for paramilitary organisations and extremist groups, and it was theorised that Andreas Gruber had belonged to one and either embezzled funds or committed treason. Investigators sought to question an individual associated with one such extremist group, 33-year-old former soldier Adolf Gump. After World War I, Gump joined a Bavarian paramilitary faction and eventually formed a commando unit within the group. In 1921, he participated in the massacre of nine farmers, which he often boasted about.
和小刀。这两件物品上都没有提取到指纹。鉴于当时巴伐利亚的社会和文化气候，谋杀案的政治动机也被考虑在内。该地区是准军事组织和极端主义集团的温床，有人推论安德烈亚斯·格鲁伯曾属于其中一个组织，要么挪用了资金，要么犯下了叛国罪。调查人员试图讯问一个与此类极端主义组织相关的人员，33岁的前士兵阿道夫·甘普。第一次世界大战后，甘普加入了一个巴伐利亚准军事派系，并最终在该组织内部组建了一个突击队。1921年，他参与了一场针对九名农民的大屠杀，他经常吹嘘这件事。
Unsubstantiated rumours accused Gump of having been romantically involved with Victoria Gabriel. However, he could not be found. Three weeks into the investigation, police in Munich received a letter requesting they look into Carl Gabriel, Victoria's former husband. Carl had been reportedly killed in action during the war eight years earlier, yet his body was never returned to Germany, and stories circulated of soldiers who faked their death to live under assumed identities. The theory was that Carl had done exactly that, but upon learning of the incestuous relationship between Victoria and Andreas, returned to hinder Kyfek to murder the entire family.
未经证实的传言指控甘普曾与维多利亚·加布里埃尔有恋爱关系。然而，他不知所踪。调查进行三周后，慕尼黑警方收到一封信，请求他们调查维多利亚的前夫卡尔·加布里埃尔。据报道，卡尔八年前在战争中阵亡，但他的尸体从未被运回德国，并且流传着士兵伪造死亡以使用假名生活的 Huarong 故事。这一理论认为卡尔正是这样做的，但在得知维多利亚和安德烈亚斯之间的乱伦关系后，返回辛特凯费克谋杀了全家。
Police spoke with several of Carl's fellow officers who confirmed they had seen his body after his death and revealed he was buried in a war cemetery in France. Other theories centered on Carl's family that they carried out the murders for financial gain or revenge for their son's unhappy marriage. Several locals expressed suspicion towards brothers Carl and Anton Bikler, well-known thieves who had worked at Hinder Kyfek during the harvest seasons. One witness claimed Carl Bikler had proposed the idea of robbing Hinder Kyfek, while another noticed the brothers had recently been spending a significant amount of money, despite being unemployed. Hinder Kyfek's former maid, Crescent's Riga,
警方与卡尔的几位同事进行了交谈，他们证实死后见过他的尸体，并透露他被埋葬在法国的一个战争公墓里。其他推测则集中在卡尔的家人身上，认为他们是为了谋取经济利益或为儿子不幸的婚姻复仇而实施了谋杀。几位当地居民对卡尔和安东·比克勒兄弟表示怀疑，这两个人是著名的盗贼，曾在收割季节在欣德凯费克工作过。一位目击者称，卡尔·比克勒曾提议抢劫欣德凯费克，而另一位目击者则注意到，这对兄弟尽管失业，最近却花了一大笔钱。欣德凯费克的前女佣克雷森茨·里加，
explained that the brothers were familiar with the layout of the property, and Anton was one of the few people whom the family dog never barked at. According to Crescent's, Anton once remarked that the family needed to be killed. When she informed her employers of his comment, they dismissed the threat. This incident prompted Crescent's to quit as she feared the Bikler brothers were planning an attack. Carl Bikler was taken in for questioning, during which he professed his innocence and was able to provide an alibi for himself and Anton. The brothers had been drinking in a bar 51km south of Hinder Kyfek at the time of the murders. Months later, on August 2, the mother of another set of brothers Carl and Andreas Schreyer
解释说，兄弟俩对这处房产的布局很熟悉，安东是少数几个连家里的狗从不对其吠叫的人之一。据克雷森茨回忆，安东曾说过这家人必须被杀死。当她把他的言论告知雇主时，他们却不把这个威胁当回事。这一事件促使克雷森茨辞职，因为她担心比克勒兄弟正在策划袭击。卡尔·比克勒被带去接受讯问，期间他坚称自己无辜，并能为自己和安东提供不在场证明。案发时，兄弟俩正在欣德凯费克以南51公里的一家酒吧喝酒。几个月后，即8月2日，另一对兄弟卡尔和安德烈亚斯·施赖尔的母亲
confessed to a neighbour that her sons were responsible for the crime. The Schreyer brothers were arrested and a hearing took place the following month, but both men were released due to a lack of evidence. Other suspects included a former soldier who had escaped from a Bavarian mental health hospital a year before the murders. He was believed to have burgled properties in the vicinity of Hinder Kyfek, though there was no evidence linking him to the farm, and his whereabouts remain unknown. Suspicions were also cast on Lorenz Schlittenbauer, the neighbour who discovered the bodies at Hinder Kyfek. Lorenz had resided in the same farmhouse on the fringe of Groben his entire life.
向邻居坦白，她的儿子们对这起罪行负有责任。施赖尔兄弟被捕，并在次月举行了听证会，但由于缺乏证据，两人均被释放。其他嫌疑人还包括一名在谋杀案发生前一年从巴伐利亚一家精神病院逃跑的前士兵。据信他在欣德凯费克附近盗窃过财产，但没有证据将他与该农场联系起来，其下落至今不明。人们还将怀疑的目光投向了洛伦兹·施利滕鲍尔，即在欣德凯费克发现尸体的邻居。洛伦兹一生都住在格罗本边缘的同一个农舍里。
He also served as the village guide, collaborating with the local council and acting as a spokesperson for the community. Two weeks after his wife passed away in 1918, Lorenz commenced a brief romantic relationship with Victoria Gabriel, who was 13 years his junior. In late 1918, he asked Andreas for permission to marry Victoria on the condition that Andreas ceased having sexual relations with her. Andreas reportedly replied, we will see. When Lorenz next saw Victoria, she said she was pregnant with his child. He refused to accept this, convinced that Andreas was really the father. Three days after Joseph was born, Lorenz reported Victoria and her father to the authorities
他还担任村庄向导，与当地议会合作并担任社区发言人。1918年妻子去世两周后，洛伦兹与比他小13岁的维多利亚·加布里埃尔开始了一段短暂的恋情。1918年末，他向安德烈亚斯请求允许迎娶维多利亚，条件是安德烈亚斯停止与她发生性关系。据报道，安德烈亚斯回答说，我们走着瞧。洛伦兹下次见到维多利亚时，她称自己怀上了他的孩子。他拒绝接受这一点，确信安德烈亚斯才是真正的父亲。约瑟夫出生三天后，洛伦兹向当局举报了维多利亚和她的父亲
for incest, and once again Andreas was taken into custody. Victoria begged him to withdraw his statement, offering to reimburse the child support he would be required to pay if he claimed paternity. Lorenz agreed, and the charges were dropped. He was named as Joseph's father, a relationship he occasionally acknowledged, but more often denied. He maintained a polite, though tense relationship with Andreas and Victoria, while gossiping and criticizing them around town. Upon discovering the brutalized bodies of his neighbors, including his alleged son, Lorenz was remarkably calm. Witnesses commented on his apparent eagerness to disrupt the crime scene, with Detective George Ryan Gruber noting in his initial report, quote,
犯下了乱伦罪，安德烈亚斯再次被拘留。维多利亚恳求他撤回陈述，并提出如果他承认自己是父亲，她将补偿他所需支付的抚养费。洛伦兹同意了，指控被撤销。他被指定为约瑟夫的父亲，这一父子关系他偶尔承认，但更多时候予以否认。他与安德烈亚斯和维多利亚保持着礼貌但紧张的关系，同时在镇上对他们评头论足、加以批评。在发现邻居（包括他所谓的儿子）饱受摧残的尸体时，洛伦兹表现得异常冷静。目击者评论了他迫不及待想要破坏犯罪现场的表现，侦探乔治·瑞安·格鲁伯在最初的报告中指出，引述道，
it should not be left unmentioned that the head of the district, Lorenz Schlittenbauer, showed a somewhat excited behavior. He talks a lot and also makes himself otherwise important, took care of everything, and was also well acquainted with the domestic circumstances of the murdered. Although Detective Ryan Gruber also noted in his report that there was no known motive for Lorenz to commit the killings. Jacob Siegel was also present when the bodies were found. He had been suspicious of Lorenz since he opened the farmstead's front door with the key he claimed was already in the lock. Jacob openly referred to Lorenz as the Kyfecker murderer, prompting Lorenz to sue him for defamation and publish an article in the local paper that read,
不能不提的是，地区负责人洛伦兹·施利滕鲍尔表现出某种兴奋的行为。他话很多，也表现得很重要，包揽了一切，而且对被害人的家庭情况也非常熟悉。尽管侦探瑞安·格鲁伯也在报告中指出，没有已知的动机能让洛伦兹实施谋杀。发现尸体时雅各布·西格尔也在场。自从洛伦兹用他声称已经在锁里的钥匙打开农场前门以来，他就一直对洛伦兹心存怀疑。雅各布公开称洛伦兹为凯费克谋杀犯，这促使洛伦兹以诽谤罪起诉他，并在当地报纸上发表了一篇文章，上面写着：
I warn anyone who spreads rumors that I was involved in the murder in Hinterkijfek. From now on, I will go against anybody spreading such rumors, whether wealthy or not, with a lawsuit. Four years after the murders, the Schlittenbauer's home burned down. Villages gathered to help extinguish the flames, but the damage was severe, and many of Lorenz's important documents, including some relating to Joseph Gruber's paternity, were destroyed. That same year, Detective George Ryan Gruber stepped down from the Hinterkijfek case, and criminal inspector Martin Riedmeier took over. On the nine-year anniversary of the crime in 1931, Riedmeier reopened the case and re-interviewed key witnesses, including a tearful Lorenz Schlittenbauer
我警告任何散布我参与辛特基费克谋杀案谣言的人。从现在开始，无论富有与否，我都会用诉讼来对付任何散布此类谣言的人。谋杀案发生四年后，施利滕鲍尔的家被大火烧毁。村民们聚集在一起帮忙灭火，但损失惨重，洛伦兹的许多重要文件，包括一些与约瑟夫·格鲁伯生父身份有关的文件，都被毁了。同年，侦探乔治·瑞安·格鲁伯卸任辛特基费克案，刑事督察马丁·里德迈尔接手。在1931年案件发生九周年之际，里德迈尔重启了案件并重新走访了关键证人，其中包括泪流满面的洛伦兹·施利滕鲍尔，
who continued to profess his innocence. He attributed reports of his suspicious behavior to his, quote, helpful actions at the crime scene. Riedmeier concluded, clues for further action are no longer available. A decade after the murders took place, an article in a German newspaper reflected on their lasting impact on the quiet rural community, quote, the gruesome atrocity still holds the residents of the Schrobenhausen area far and wide in terror. The case is still much talked of today. The relatives of the Gruber and Gabriel families were also investigated as possible suspects, with financial benefit considered a motive, as Cecilia's daughter from her first marriage
他继续坚称自己无辜。他将自己可疑行为的报道归咎于他在犯罪现场所做的，引述道，乐于助人的行为。里德迈尔得出结论，进一步行动的线索已不复存在。谋杀案发生十年后，德国一家报纸的一篇文章反思了它们对这个安静的农村社区产生的持久影响，引述道，这起可怕的暴行至今仍在惊吓着施罗本豪森地区的广大居民。这个案子至今仍是人们津津乐道的话题。格鲁伯和加布里埃尔家族的亲属也被作为潜在嫌疑人进行了调查，经济利益被认为是一个动机，因为塞西莉亚第一次婚姻的女儿
had lent Victoria her substantial amount of money for farm repairs. Yet, this line of inquiry didn't progress far. In 1937, the two brothers of Victoria's deceased husband, Carl Gabriel, allegedly confessed to their maid of committing the Hinterkäfek murders for monetary gain. Both men were arrested but subsequently released without charge three weeks later, after proving they had purchased the Hinterkäfek estate with their own savings. By the end of the 1930s, the investigation was set aside completely as the Second World War commenced. During the 1940s, bombings by Allied forces on German cities such as Nuremberg and Munich destroyed much of the evidence relating to the case, including vital documents and the skulls of the victims.
曾借给维多利亚一大笔钱用于农场修缮。然而，这条调查路线并没有取得多大进展。1937年，维多利亚已故丈夫卡尔·加布里埃尔的两个兄弟据称向女佣承认，为了金钱利益实施了辛特卡费克谋杀案。两名男子随后被捕，但在证明他们是用自己的积蓄购买了辛特卡费克庄园后，三周后无罪释放。到20世纪30年代末，随着第二次世界大战的爆发，调查彻底被搁置。20世纪40年代，盟军对纽伦堡和慕尼黑等德国城市的轰炸摧毁了大部分与该案有关的证据，包括至关重要的文件和受害者的头骨。
Six years after the war, interest in the cold case was revived when a series of long-form articles about the murders were penned by journalist Joseph Ludwig Hecker and published in a Bavarian newspaper. As a result, several German prisoners of war came forward, alleging to have been released by a Bavarian-speaking Soviet officer who claimed responsibility for the Hinterkäfek murders. These assertions reignited rumors that Carl Gabriel was indeed alive and carried out the crime, but were later dismissed when the men revised their statements, reducing their credibility. In May 1952, longtime suspect and extremist group member Adolf Gump was once again implicated. Adolf had passed away eight years earlier, but according to statements his sister later
战后六年，当记者约瑟夫·路德维希·赫克撰写的一系列关于谋杀案的长篇报道发表在巴伐利亚的一家报纸上时，人们对这起陈年旧案的兴趣重新燃起。结果，几名德国战俘挺身而出，声称他们曾被一名会说巴伐利亚语的苏联军官释放，该军官声称对辛特卡费克的谋杀案负责。这些断言重新点燃了关于卡尔·加布里埃尔确实活着并实施了这起犯罪的谣言，但随着这些男子修改了他们的供词，其可信度降低，这些传言随后被驳回。1952年5月，长期以来的嫌疑人、极端组织成员阿道夫·古普再次被牵连其中。阿道夫八年前就已去世，但根据他妹妹后来
made to a priest, he confessed on his deathbed to carrying out the killings with his brother Anton. Following this revelation, Anton was arrested, only to be released weeks later, and the Gump brothers were eventually ruled out of the investigation entirely. In 1955, the Hinterkäfek case was shelved indefinitely. Despite going cold, Germany's fascination with the mystery ensured theories and conjecture endured throughout the years. In 1971, Carl and Andreas Schreier, the brothers who were briefly arrested in 1922 after their mother reportedly confided in a neighbour about their involvement in the murders, were cast back into the spotlight. A woman claiming to be the daughter
向神父透露的说法，他在临终前承认自己和兄弟安东一起实施了谋杀。这一消息曝光后，安东被捕，但在几周后被释放，古普兄弟最终被完全排查出调查范围。1955年，辛特卡费克案被无限期搁置。尽管沦为悬案，但德国人对这个谜团的着迷确保了各种理论和推测多年来一直存在。1971年，卡尔和安德烈亚斯·施赖尔兄弟重新成为人们关注的焦点。这对兄弟曾在1922年因其母亲向邻居吐露他们参与谋杀后被短暂逮捕。一名自称是
of the neighbour penned a letter to the Attorney General, had explained that during the visit, Mrs Schreier reportedly remarked, quote, Andreas regretted that he lost his penknife. Curiously, the discovery of the bloody penknife at Hinterkäfek had been kept under wraps by investigators. Police interrogated the woman who wrote the letter, but with no evidence to support her claims, the investigation faltered once again. In 1978, journalist Peter Leuchner published the first book on the murders, titled Hinterkäfek, Germany's most mysterious murder case. The book was such a success that it sold out for extended periods. In 1981, film director Hans Fiegel adapted the book into a documentary called Hinterkäfek, symbol of the young canny.
邻居女儿的女性致信总检察长，解释说在访问期间，施赖尔夫人曾说过，引述据称，安德烈亚斯为弄丢了折叠刀而感到遗憾。奇怪的是，在辛特卡费克发现带血的折叠刀一事一直被调查人员秘而不宣。警方对写信的女子进行了讯问，但由于没有证据支持她的说法，调查再次陷入停滞。1978年，记者彼得·洛伊希纳出版了第一本关于这起谋杀案的书，名为《辛特卡费克：德国最神秘的谋杀案》。这本书大获成功，长期处于售罄状态。1981年，电影导演汉斯·菲格尔将该书改编成了一部名为《辛特卡费克：年轻精明者的象征》的纪录片。
Other documentaries on the case followed over the years, as well as a play, a radio program, and a fictionalised film. Twenty years after the release of Leuchner's book, he published a second edition after gaining access to further documents from Munich. In the mid-1980s, final interviews were conducted with several of Sealy Gabriel's former classmates. Detective Conrad Mueller of the Ingolstadt police assisted and found himself fascinated by the unsolved case. He continued looking into the murders well after his retirement in the 1990s, collecting a total of 12 binders worth of evidence. Teaming up with criminal profiler Klaus Wiest, the pair theorised that the slayings were personally motivated,
多年来，关于此案的其他纪录片也相继问世，还有一出戏剧、一个广播节目和一部虚构电影。在洛伊希纳的书出版二十年后，他在获得慕尼黑的更多文件后出版了第二版。在20世纪80年代中期，人们对塞利·加布里埃尔的几位老同学进行了最后的采访。因戈尔施塔特警方的侦探康拉德·穆勒协助了调查，并发现自己对这起未破的悬案着迷。他在20世纪90年代退休后很久仍在继续调查这起谋杀案，总共收集了12个文件夹的证据。两人与犯罪侧写师克劳斯·维斯特合作，推测这起谋杀案是有个人动机的，
with the strangulation marks on Victoria indicating she had been the prime target. In 2007, 15 students from a Bavarian police academy looked into the case to see if it could be solved using 21st century techniques. They compiled 200 pages of documents and critiqued the shortcomings of the original investigation, including how police neglected to interview the mechanic who had visited the property the day the bodies were found, until three years later. Like Conrad Mueller and Klaus Wiest, the students suspected the killer was personally motivated due to the manner in which they had concealed the victim's bodies. They concluded it wasn't possible to solve the crime due to the lack of forensic evidence,
维多利亚脖子上的勒痕表明她一直是首要目标。2007年，巴伐利亚警察学院的15名学员研究了这起案件，看能否用21世纪的技术将其破解。他们汇编了200页的文件，并批评了最初调查的缺陷，包括警方直到三年后才去采访在发现尸体当天访问过该物业的机械师。就像康拉德·穆勒和克劳斯·维斯特一样，由于凶手掩盖受害者尸体的方式，学生们怀疑凶手具有个人动机。他们得出结论，由于缺乏法医证据、
the significant loss of documents, and the death of key witnesses. They did establish a prime suspect, but declined to name the individual out of respect for surviving family members and descendants. The Hinterkleifek murders captivated armchair sleuths and independent investigators in Germany and around the world. In 2017, American crime writer Bill James and his daughter Rachel McCarthy James co-authored a book titled The Man from the Train, which chronicles their attempt to solve Iwer's Voliska Racks murders, in which six members of the Moore family and two guests were murdered during a brutal home invasion in 1912. After studying the case and similar
大量文件的丢失以及关键证人的死亡，要破获这起罪案是不可能的。他们确实确定了一个头号嫌疑人，但为了尊重幸存的家属和后代，拒绝透露此人的姓名。辛特克莱费克谋杀案迷住了德国乃至全世界的沙发侦探和独立调查员。2017年，美国犯罪小说家比尔·詹姆斯和他的女儿蕾切尔·麦卡锡·詹姆斯合著了一本书，名为《火车上的男人》，记录了他们试图破解1912年伊维尔·沃利斯卡·雷克斯谋杀案的尝试，当时莫尔家族的六名成员和两名客人在一次残酷的入室抢劫中被杀害。在研究了该案和类似的
contemporary murders all over the United States, the father-daughter team concluded that the unsolved crimes were the work of a single perpetrator, a German-born farmhand named Paul Mueller, who fled Massachusetts after he was suspected of murdering the family that employed him. They theorized he returned to his homeland, where he later murdered the Gruber-Gabriel family in the same manner, though no concrete evidence supports these allegations. In 2018, former Detective Conrad Mueller finally parted with the evidence he had collected on the Hinterkleifek case and gave it to the Bavarian Police Museum in the city of Ingolstadt. Mueller's documents now sit alongside a range of other displays at the museum's Hinterkleifek
全美同类谋杀案后，这对父女团队得出结论，这些未破的罪行是一个名叫保罗·穆勒的德国籍农场雇工一人所为，他在因涉嫌谋杀雇佣他的家庭而受到怀疑后逃离了马萨诸塞州。他们推测他回到了祖国，后来以同样的方式谋杀了格鲁伯-加布里埃尔家族，尽管没有任何具体证据支持这些指控。2018年，前侦探康拉德·穆勒终于割舍了他收集的关于辛特克莱费克案的证据，并将其交给了因戈尔施塔特市的巴伐利亚警察博物馆。穆勒的文件现在与博物馆辛特克莱费克
exhibit, which aims to highlight the evolution of police methods over the past century. The exhibition has attracted thousands of visitors over the past several years and will close on October 6, 2019. Hinterkleifek remains one of Germany's most talked about unsolved crimes. Over the years, police have considered a total of 105 potential suspects, but despite several arrests, no one has ever been charged. Myths have sprung up around the case, including that former maid, Crescent's Riga, left Hinterkleifek after repeatedly hearing someone in the attic at night, although nothing in her police statement indicates this is true. In recent years, a local guide began offering ghost tours of the site, with participants meeting in
展览中的一系列其他展品陈列在一起，该展览旨在突出过去一个世纪警方侦查手段的演变。过去几年里，该展览吸引了数千名游客，并将于2019年10月6日闭幕。辛特克莱费克仍然是德国最受关注的未破悬案之一。多年来，警方总共考虑了105名潜在嫌疑人，但尽管多次逮捕，却从未有人被起诉。围绕该案涌现出许多神话，包括前女佣克雷森茨·里加在多次听到夜里阁楼有人声后离开了辛特克莱费克，尽管她的警方笔录中没有任何内容表明这是真的。近年来，当地的一位向导开始提供该地点的幽灵之旅，参与者在
the town of Weidhofen and proceeding on foot through fields and forests to the empty property. For the relatives of those connected to the crime, Hinterkleifek continued to cause suffering long after the murders. Lorenz Schlittenbauer, considered by many to be the prime suspect, died in 1941. His descendants have spoken of the negative impact the Association had on their own lives. In 2010, his daughter Regina told the media she and her siblings were ostracised throughout their lives, commenting, at some point, there must be peace. After the Hinterkleifek farmstead was demolished in 1923, a wayside shrine was erected on the land and still stands today. Marked with a crucifix, the small white memorial is framed by a tiny fence
维德霍芬镇集合，然后徒步穿过田野和森林前往空置的庄园。对于与这起罪行相关的人的亲属来说，辛特克莱费克在谋杀案发生很久之后仍继续造成痛苦。被许多人认为是头号嫌疑人的洛伦兹·施利滕鲍尔于1941年去世。他的后代曾谈到这一关联对他们自己生活的负面影响。2010年，他的女儿雷吉娜对媒体说，她和兄弟姐妹一生都遭到排挤，并评论道，在某个时候，必须迎来平静。1923年辛特克莱费克农舍被拆除后，土地上竖起了一座路边神龛，至今仍耸立在那里。这座白色的纪念碑上有个十字架，周围环绕着一个小栅栏
and neatly manicured plants. An inscription reads, Godless murderer's hand fell the Gruber Gabriel family here on March 31, 1922. This inscription is followed by the name of each victim and their year of birth. The former land of Hinterkleifek is now used for agriculture. Over at the Whitehofen Cemetery, a tall, dark grey obelisk marks the resting place of Andreas, Cecilia, Victoria, Sealy, Joseph and Maria. It bears a similar message to the shrine, but has also been engraved with a brief verse from the Bible's Book of Psalms. God remembers those who suffer, he does not forget their cry, and he punishes those who wrong them. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和精心修剪的植物。上面刻着铭文：不神圣的杀手之手于1922年3月31日在此杀害了格鲁伯加布里埃尔家族。铭文后面是每个受害者的名字和他们的出生年份。辛特克莱费克的旧土地现在用于农业。在怀特霍芬公墓，一个高大的深灰色方尖碑标志着安德烈亚斯、塞西莉亚、维多利亚、塞利、约瑟夫和玛丽亚的安息之地。它刻有与神龛相似的信息，但也刻上了圣经《诗篇》中的一小节诗句。上帝铭记那些受苦的人，他不会忘记他们的哭喊，他会惩罚那些冤枉他们的人。此剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。